In a previous video, we started working
on our new storage container.
We got the container just before the winter break.
Then, we opened some space around it,
and finally we built a big roof on top.
Now, it's time to start making the storage system.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
One side will be our new material bank.
To store offcuts to be used later,
and items that could have a second life.
Such as windows or doors.
The other side will hold our new waste system.
We like the idea of not being a shame,
with the waste we generate.
And, since our project is based on sustainability...
We also like to put the waste in the front.
To, in the future, give a new value
to what now is considered garbage.
But first, we need to do some landscaping
work around the container.
For that, we will get a hand from the general help team.
At the moment, I'm in the area that we cleared of last season.
But, unfortunately, the brambles are already growing back...
The idea is to bring in humans, so that they step on the brambles,
and the brambles stay away.
But, to get the humans here, we need
to make the place a bit more comfortable.
So, let's do that!
We try to remove the bass from the old mimosas.
And, pull the new, sprouting ones.
Okay, here we are trying a new strategy,
Putting the top of the mimosas on the bottom.
To create like a barrier that gets the rainwater,
and retains it into the ground.
So, all this soil that I'm standing on,
we got from leveling the container.
Which, we can now use to put on top of the mimosa tops.
So, here we have a strawberry tree,
and we don't want people to step on it...
So, we are going to put this little sign here.
- So beautiful!
It is beautiful!
We also always try to take care of
the native species we find around.
Here, next to the medronheiro, we have a nice open area!
We would like to create this
as a general help space.
So, some chairs, a table and a flat levelled area could help.
Okay, on three?
One...
Two...
Three!
Thank you!
- Maybe we should bring our board in...
Oh, yeah! That's nice!
- You take care of the cameras today!
Then, we cleared a circular area to be
the new Human Hour space.
And then, our journey to find useful uses to the mimosas,
this big bench was built.
- It's a good two seater.
You should have a little tub of tea and coffee here.
To connect all these new places,
we made multiple paths with the wood chips.
Come on, people!
Work! Work!
To finish the job, we had to cut this mimosa,
that was almost falling onto the new roof.
- Now, the roof is safe!
Okay, so, the area has been transforming quite a bit!
Let's have a look!
So, in the area, we have been taking quite a bit more of mimosas.
It's never bad to take out more, but then,
what do we do with all that material?
We chopped it up in smaller pieces this time,
and lay it down on the waterlines.
This is to stop the water from sliding down,
but also help to decompose it faster.
With this little bridge, it becomes quite funny.
And, obviously, the native ones, they are highly cared.
We also got the opportunity to create more neat meeting spaces.
In this case, a new space for general help,
to have their Monday morning meeting.
So, here we have a beautiful creation,
made out of mimosa.
You can have a look on the research module!
This shapes the new Human Hour space.
Where we come together by the end of the week.
So, enough about this area.
General Help did a great job,
but we are going out towards the container.
We are going to start to build our material bank.
We have the roof ready, so we have a nice dry area
around the container to start to store materials.
In this first material bank,
we will store mainly wood in different sizes.
Now, we try to standardize the sizes of the wood a bit,
that we use in the Kamp.
In order to, in the future, be able to disassemble what we do.
To reuse that wood, and like that,
expanding the life of the materials.
For this project, we have Eemeli, that will take care of the design,
the building and the timing of the project.
If you want...
- I can.
First, I dug a trench, so we can have electricity in the container.
The power we use in the Kamp comes from the solar panels,
It's stored in batteries in the kitchen container.
Just like that, we have another building
connected to our off grid system.
So, I'm going to start building the shelves,
that will make our storage system.
We wanted to design something that is strong,
with common materials and to be easily replicated by others.
It will consist of materials that will be attached to the container wall.
They will hold some arms.
It will be adjustable, so it can be adapted
to many different needs and materials.
I will start by doing the first piece,
to see if everything works.
I was so nervous about the welding bottle,
that I forgot to film it, but...
It seems to be fine!
Here is the result!
First one done!
Now, we need to do this times 24...
Let's go!
That's actually 23, because we have one.
Okay, cool!
Now, I have all the pieces, so I can start welding.
It will be a lot of welding, but I got new clothes,
so I should be good to go...
And also, look!
A good match.
And the welding machine, it happens to be a Finnish brand.
So, that's even nicer!
All the arms are ready!
They can be sanded and painted!
But first, I need to work on the U-beams...
First, by cutting them, and then do a bunch of crazy stuff.
So, this is how it goes...
The arm goes inside of the new beam.
And then, there's a hole and a bolt that holds everything together.
Next, we do a lot of holes...
Okay...
Now, I got all the U-beams drilled.
The only thing is to drill the placement,
or where you attach it to the container.
It goes for each end one,
and maybe one in the middle.
I'm not sure yet...
Now, I'm going to mark their places.
Done!
Okay, the arms are ready to be painted next, but...
I think somebody will help me with the painting.
Chester!
Can you help me with the painting?
No...
Timo, you want to do a little bit of sanding?
- I have to go shopping...
Sorry.
I would love to, otherwise!
They sanded and painted everything, to prevent rust.
I get used to say this, but the 40 x 40 x 3 millimeters U-beams,
they have a good strength for our need!
Now that all pieces are made, we can start assembling.
The container is not perfectly straight,
so we need to hit some of the bumps back.
To make it more even...
- It seems that there is no other solution?
No, so, it's hammertime...
Without this one, it's awful!
- What's happening here?
But, it's pretty cool going inside!
This is a sound test.
- Yeah?
Okay, I'm ready!
Do you see that?
The area, where you hit with the hammer, is hotter!
Makes sense...
It's fun to see!
Okay, wait a minute!
Here, I have a new thermal camera that we are trying,
but maybe Dave can talk more about it!
So, we got this thermal cam made by Topdon,
and they send it to us, so we could try and showcase the features it has.
And, this thing, it gives you a high resolution infrared image
on your phone screen, and it shows the temperature readings.
You can tap on the image to get a point-temperature info.
You have this mode, where you can draw a line on the screen.
It gives you the highest and the lowest temperature points on that line.
You can also draw an area, and this will give you the hottest
and the coldest point in there.
It has a wide range of temperature measurements,
from -20 to 500 degrees.
Different settings to tailor the skill you're working with,
and the colors, and so on...
We wanted to figure out what we could use it for,
and we found a bunch of applications in Project Kamp.
First, let's have a look at our cork insulation in the office.
We found out some heat is leaking,
between the seams of the corkboard.
You can see the yellow lines more bright,
which means it's hotter.
We also had a quick check
on our solar system.
Good to see if some components overheat,
and therefore improve the layout of it.
Batteries are doing great and they're not overheating.
Another cool application is also to see
if the compost pile is working.
You can tell if it's hot enough inside there.
Looks like it is, so no need to get our hands dirty.
And, as we're renovating old buildings,
it's an interesting to see where the structure is weaker.
For instance, those corners between
the ceiling and the wall get hotter.
Which probably means there's less material.
So, we might need to reinforce those areas.
And, we couldn't avoid checking our recycled plastic roof.
It's interesting to see the difference in temperature between the sheets.
Probably because each panel
has a different plastic mix and color.
So, we did a few quick tests with the camera.
It seems like a useful tool and I can think of many other applications.
So, one cool thing, you can also hook it up to your computer,
so that you can monitor the temperature over time.
It would also be interesting to measure wildlife.
And, maybe even at night, so that you can see
the heat patterns they leave.
Maybe we can spot wildfires in the distance.
What if you have like different colors of paint,
and we can measure which one gets most hot?
So, we can see what color we should paint our buildings.
What we also like is that it's like not
an entire new device, but it's an add-on.
It's a bit like Phonebloks,
like a module for your existing phone.
Anyway, we'll continue to explore
more information in the link below.
Let's continue with the container!
Pretty good! Not bad!
Now that the container is flat, let's install the system.
After the first one was in place...
I did the same thing for the five other things, but I forgot to record it.
So sorry...
Actually, it took me a whole day to mount
the six pins to the container.
Since the container was so uneven...
So, it's just a little bit more work than I was expecting.
But now, it seems to be okay!
It's kind of loose here, but...
So, I need to add at a bolt to the middle.
Now, I just have to put the arms in.
- Good morning, Eemeli!
Good morning.
How does it look?
- Good.
How do you feel about it?
- It's not bad!
Could be worse, I think.
- Well, always can be worse.
Can I...?
Is it strong enough for me?
- I think so, yeah.
Very strong!
Now, I got the arms here.
It looks nice!
The only thing left to do is to bring all the wood here,
but I need a few more hands for that...
So, let's go and see, if there is any hands available!
Okay, this is all the wood we need to move.
There seems to be some happy people willing to help me!
So, this wood needs to go there...
Okay, one side is ready with our material bank,
and now we are going to jump to the other side!
We are going to set up our first waste point.
Eemeli is going to build it!
It will have a similar structure done for the other side
For this, we have Kevin that will start some research.
To see the state where we are at,
to be able to set up our first waste system.
Currently, we are using this recycling system.
We have three colored bins, which is based on the waste system,
that applies to all of Portugal.
The glass and paper are fairly understandable and very clear.
But, there's a problem with the yellow one,
which makes a lot of different packaging material into one bin.
For example, there are Tetra bags, plastic bags,
hard plastic, and all kinds of metal mixed into one bin...
So, it's difficult for people to understand and to do it properly.
We want to do a more detail separation on the yellow bin,
and we have done some testing.
So, let me show you.
Okay, so, this is what we have now!
You can see a lot of different materials mixed together...
With barbed wire, metal, dangerous stuff,
are all together here and it's very messy...
Either, you come to recycle, or you want to rescue
some of the material for your project.
So, I think we can do better than this.
Let me show you!
Okay, so, this is where Eemeli will be building
the new recycling system shelving.
We want to separate all kinds of material
into a more tidy rack.
So, people can recover the material more easily,
and also separate them more easily.
It's also very easy to load it onto a truck,
and send it to a recycling point.
To decide that, we also have been doing a waste audit
to count what kind of waste we're actually producing.
I can show you that as well.
So, we have stockpiled all the recyclables,
and separated them into a clear system.
To see what kind of material we actually got.
Like, for example, there's a lot of metal, coffee bags,
and Tetra bags and also a lot of plastic bags...
So, these are materials we can potentially
reuse here locally for our future project.
Or, we can stop hauling more enough
to find a trustable recycler to send it directly to them.
In case anyone is wondering why we only have
the top and the bottom part of the can...
It's because we have been using the size for another project.
So, we want to make some signs
for the recycling system.
But, the sign will placed outdoors,
so we need it to be weatherproof...
Let's see if we can make a sign out of it!
Now, the piece of wood is covered,
with the aluminum from the beer can.
So, now, we try to write the sign on it.
This is how it will look like,
and I'm quite happy about it.
So, let's make three more of them!
We have made the signs!
Let's put this onto the crates!
800 grams.
So, after the audit, we decided
to keep the glass and paper bin...
Because, it is more or less a more straight forward separation.
And, for the yellow bin, we want to do
a more detailed one, which is four categories.
One is Precious Plastic, where we keep the PPE
and HDPE, for a future project.
And then, the soft plastic, which is mainly the plastic bags,
the chip bags and the Tetra bags.
Which we can compress and save space,
and also, maybe for future projects.
And, hard plastic, which is really the plastic
that we have no idea on how to use...
But still, we want to put it into a tidy way
Metal is the more valuable one.
We separate them into aluminum,
and mixed-in metal.
We would be stockpiling them into a more bigger quantity.
Either, we send it to a trustful recycler,
or we can reuse them locally here.
We will keep doing research, and see how it goes,
and it will evolve and it depends how it goes...
We will keep improving it.
This is our first version of the recycling system!
All the bins are ready!
When the shelves are done, we can start installing them.
Here are some welds brought onto the container.
So, there is a weld seam that needs to be smoothened out...
This is a good example what the video makers actually do...
They just vandalize all the things we have.
Now that the beams are there, I can put the arms on!
- By the way, don't forget to subscribe!
♡ Thank you! ♡
The arms are all in place!
Now, it's time to make some wood supports.
Now, I need to make two more shelves.
So, three in total.
It's loud in here...
The fact that this place feels quiet and silent,
and everything is in balance in reality...w
So, almost all of the day is very noisy.
They just don't show it to you!
This is flexing quite a lot...
So, I want to add one more arm in the middle.
Better!
I broke it already...
This also works for naps.
Just some hours after we finished, it started to rain,
so we could put our storage system to the test!
- Are you dry?
I think we're good, but let's see...
Time will tell.
This is the system that we created.
So, it consists of six beams,
and six beams on each side.
The same system on both sides of the container,
We have seven holes, and into those holes,
you can put the arms.
You can mount the arm, by putting the bolt through.
The beams are bolted straight to the container.
So, we wanted to make a system,
that is simple enough to make here.
And maybe, simple enough to replicate also!
The materials that we used are standard sizes,
so it should be available everywhere you can get metal!
So, this is the waste side of the storage.
We have put the windows here from the white tent.
And also, on top, we put some things
that we don't need that often...
Also, some cocoa, gas, beer, and some crates...
We use them a lot!
And also, the spiky wire.
At some point, we probably will add some more shelves here.
I guess we just have a lot of stuff,
and this is a good dry place to store stuff.
It's good to have a system that is changeable!
The material bank is a nice upgrade,
because we can start stocking ahead of time for our projects.
That will reduce delays and most importantly,
we can start to store many materials we want to reuse properly.
For the waste system, we are still in early stages of our research.
But, there is enough improvement for the moment!
Now, it's easier to load and unload the bins.
We can align better with the local recycling facilities.
We can even think better of how to reuse and upcycle!
In the next update, we will continue clearing the mimosas
around Basekamp to improve our fire resilience.
We will do some testing and a bit of research.
Now that the outside of the container is ready,
we also have created this area around.
Where we can sit chill, or just enjoy the shade.
If you like what we do, you can support us on Patreon!
You can see the videos one week ahead,
and without advertisements.
That would be very helpful for us!
Otherwise, you can always subscribe and comment,
to help us with the algorithm.
Thank you for watching, and see you in the next update.